let me start by saying uh thank you for
making me laugh oh you're you're welcome
I'm we're happy to hear it oh yeah
that's wonderful to hear um so a bunch
of questions for you guys how did you
decide on seven episodes did peacock was
this like a like a peacock thing was
this a you guys thing was it budget
related yeah it's a little bit um H
happened a little bit outside the room
that we we weren't actually in the room
so we may not have great answer for you
it was originally a 10 episode order and
you know we were writing the episodes
quite long they're not for the most part
they're not half hours and I think that
has a lot to do with how why 10 episodes
became eight Oh I thought it was is it
Eight Episodes I thought it was seven
well well it's it's technically seven
the pilot is two episodes combined but
it'll air as one episode so you're right
it is seven episodes yeah okay he
totally had me confused one of the
things that I one of the things I
appreciate about Seth McFarland is that
in this age of PC very every one being
very careful with what they say uh Ted
shows uh your series shows it like he
makes jokes that are other people are
not making you know um and so can can
you sort of talk about that that the
series willing to like make like you
know what I mean not yeah I mean we we
feel the same way and that was part of
what attracted us to this project
because it's not something we're used to
doing um I was remembering recently that
like when so Seth wrote the pilot and
sent it to us obviously early on because
we we were in before that uh and I
remember getting those pages and get I
went to the into my backyard to read the
the pilot thinking like what have we
gotten ourselves into and by the bottom
of page one top of two I can't exactly
remember there was a joke there I was
like I haven't seen the joke like this
in a while this is going to be on TV I
like laugh out loud in my backyard and
and I found it to be such a relief and
thought you know I think audiences might
find this to be a relief that it's that
it's just out there funny um taking some
chances yeah and I think one of the
great ways that we sort of hoping to get
away with it is you know we balanced it
out with a family that can push back
against Ted at sort of his more um
egregious comments and egregious jokes
so I think that will help us get away
with some of the the bigger bigger
harder jokes was there a line of
dialogue or something in in this season
that you're like are we actually getting
away with this like this is great yeah
there probably were many the one I was
just referring to was in again the pilot
that Seth wrote with the eye contact
joke which is at the is on like I said
on page one I was like wow that's that's
specific that that's that's Vivid um and
so that we really start the ground you
know we start off running and uh keep
running yeah I I you know I'm worried
that if I say it it won't you won't be
able to use the interview but um Ted has
a
run Ted has a run about um a nickname
for polish people that I just found
hilarious at the time and I I I'm glad
that it's it made the Final Cut I read
could be wrong that originally when this
was being developed they were thinking
about it or maybe you guys were thinking
about it as like a multicam Allah Al
type situation were you looking at Alf
and saying we can do that just with Ted
we weren't looking at Al but we were
talking about doing it as a multicam and
looking at the feasibility of doing that
uh you know just technically because it
is sort of a technical Challenge and
also
it's a technical Challenge and you would
have an audience watching that technical
Challenge and trying to keep them you
know a live audience engaged so uh as we
sort of De developed it and discussed it
with Seth it slowly turned into a single
camera and we were very happy that it
did although it would have been an
interesting challenge to try to make
that Ted as a multicam yeah and by I'm
always watching Al um so that wouldn't
have been that different um also you
know we we have a lot of experience with
single cam Seth obviously has a lot of
experience with the movies which are
essentially single cam and so it just
made sense to go that way we obviously
uh were there any ideas that came close
to being in these seven episodes that
ultimately like how did you decide on
the the seven that you went with and did
you have like a room with like 25 good
ideas and you're like what's the best
seven yeah certainly I mean let's hope
they were good ideas but as often
happens it what happened what happened
with the show often happens which is you
bring a team of people together
and they're excited about the project
and so in those first few days of the
The Writer's room a lot of ideas go up
on the Whiteboard and then you wind up
sort of pulling those and pairing them
together and wind up with the the final
version but a lot of funny stuff was
left up there on the board and uh we you
know hopefully someday get used I
believe that one of the things about
this is that uh it's uh it's episodic
and not serialized so can you sort of
talk about was there a lot of debate do
we want to do something serialized or do
we want to make it where uh Allah Modern
Family where maybe you don't have to
watch the previous episode to enjoy this
episode yes I think we we always and I
think Seth is I I know Seth was with us
wanted to keep it uh as as an episodic
comedy first of all that's just what we
do and it's it's I think how we think of
comedies and it just allows you to mix
and match change the order of things and
really just treat each episode as its
own
finite um Arc that you're trying to you
know perfect or hone as opposed to
trying to connecting it to other other
uh other stories yeah that that said we
do have a a very loose Arc of John and
Ted junor year of of high school and so
like you know you go through the year
with the holidays and and then the
ending up on the prom and so I you know
it it is episodic but it does tell the
story of a year one of the things that I
I grew up in New England and uh I
laughed at uh just when someone
mentioned Fleet bank I just started
because I went to Fleet bank and um so
and there's a lot of references to like
80s and 90s stuff my question is in the
writer room are you guys like making a
list of like these random offthe cuff
80s and 90s things and then sort of
figuring out where you can put those
references in or are you sort of doing
the episode and then saying how can we
put in some little nods to the period I
think it's you know you let the idea
drive that and the scene drive that and
then you're just looking for
specificity as you're sort of tell
trying to tell that story as opposed to
try to like try to like shoehorn in a
reference I think that that's at least
how I approach it yeah and that said
there was a large um New England
presence on the writing staff so those
references were not hard to come up with
at all yeah the only objection I have to
the series is that every episode someone
wasn't drinking Dunkin Donuts right
absolutely yeah I was recently watching
one and and I was like I couldn't
believe we got it into a Katherine Gibbs
uh secretarial School reference like
that's that's a joke for that's a joke
for like you know 200 people right but
that listen I I was sitting in a
hospitality room doing junket yesterday
watching episodes through episode 5 and
I'm sitting there and there were times I
was just laughing like a crazy person
and everyone's just looking at me I'm
like you'll you'll see it eventually you
know that's to hear yeah that is great
to hear we we really hope that it's a
show that people laugh out loud at and
just you know enjoy in that way
certainly like like I said the thing
about Seth is that he's willing to put
jokes in that I'm not seeing in other
shows like everyone is so safe yeah we
feel this we feel the same way and
hopefully you know hopefully it's it's
well received and a bit of a a relief
for everyone that that that that's
happening uh so one of the things about
the show is I watched the first few
episodes and they were mostly they were
done but then I watched I think episode
five yesterday where I really got to see
like the behind the scenes of the making
of the show where no animation was done
and I was seeing it like rough and uh it
was fascinating to watch and it made me
realize perhaps the technology is only
available now to like sort of pull
something like that off can you talk
about the challenges of making a show
like this where you're doing the main
character is animated and trying to
figure it out on set yes so that that
challenge was something that really Drew
us to the project we're like this is
this is a cool thing we've never done
this we've done a little bit of CGI
never a CGI character certainly not a
CGI character in every scene so it was a
technical challenge luckily Seth has a
team in place that really is up to that
challenge and so unset for us it was
practically seamless it w what it looked
like in in practice normally was running
a scene with a stuffed bear for
reference of size and lighting and just
general blocking and then film filming
that once so that again you have that
reference pulling the bear and then fil
filming empty space uh and then begins
the post-production process that you
were talking about where you where you
see various layers being added to the to
the bear and and you do have to when
editing um account for that not so there
there's a certain point where you're
editing an empty frame and you have to
sort of no to hold because even though
Ted isn't there yet he's going to maybe
do something interesting physically that
isn't even covered in the dialogue so
those are the small challenges that
arise yeah and you know one of the
reasons it was so seamless for us is
obviously Seth's team but also the cast
was remarkable at transitioning from
running a scene with the stuff be there
and knowing where to look and then when
you pull it they had it down perfectly
of of where to look the eyelines are and
so you really can't say too many good
too many you can't enough you can't say
enough about how good the cast was at
yes that's it on that note thank you so
much for giving me your time I really do
hope it's a huge hit for you guys and
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating today thanks so much thank
you